il ya trois théorème dévastateur des
mathématiques de la démocratie ces trois
théorème semble démontrer qu'il ya
quelque chose de fondamentalement
erronée dans le concept même de
démocratie
le premier théorème et le théorème
d'arreau ce théorème affirme que la
seule manière de combiner des
préférences individuelles en une
préférence de groupes en satisfaisant
les principe d'unanimité et
d'indépendance vis-à-vis des
alternatives non pertinentes et la
dictature
le second theora mais le drame de guy
board satterthwaite il affirme que le
seul scrutin unanime et sans dilemme du
vote utile est la dictature
le troisième théorème est un autre terme
de guy barde il affirme que si l'on
autorise les scrutins aléatoire alors le
seul scrutin unanime anonyme et 110 m du
vote utile est la dictature aller à tour
et avant que vous ne trouviez ça
scandaleux
sachez qu'il s'agit bien de théorèmes
mathématiques et qu'aucune position
idéologique ne peut remettre en cause la
validité de ses théorèmes en particulier
un corollaire de ces trois théorème est
que nos systèmes démocratiques ne sont
pas tout à fait démocratique au sens
littéral du terme
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode précédent
nos systèmes politiques poussé électeurs
à voter utile et les candidats à ne pas
toujours se présenter
voilà qui a conduit les politiques à
s'organiser sous forme de partie avec
des primaires et les électeurs à se
polariser selon une poignée de courants
de pensée antagonistes et bien ce que
disent les 3t aurel antidémocratique
c'est que tout scrutin démocratique aura
forcément ce genre de défaillance aucun
système démocratique n'est parfait ceci
étant dit on verra dans les deux
prochains épisodes des scrutins dont on
peut dire qu'ils ont moins de faiblesses
que les scrutins utilisés aujourd'hui
alors petite note je suis sûr qu'il
apparaît par evo qui veulent que je
parle du vote à la proportionnelle faut
bien voir que la proportionnelle c'est
une façon de procrastiner le moment de
l'élection du représentant de tout un
pays et de le déléguer à des politiciens
ces politiciens vont ensuite devoir
établir des coalitions faire des
magouilles accepter des concessions pour
pouvoir déterminer une ligne politique
directrice pour le pays et tout ça ça
fait pas super démocratique en tout cas
pas au sens littéral du mot
mo cra si je ne dis pas que la
proportionnelle c'est mal ça au moins
l'avantagé de ne pas trop polarisé le
peuple les électeurs mais ce que je dis
c'est que ça ne résout pas vraiment le
problème de l'élection d'un président ou
d'un premier ministre qui représente un
pays par le peuple et plus généralement
ça ne résout pas le problème du choix
d'une alternative par un électorat mais
bref assez divaguer revenons-en aux
trois théorème antidémocratique
commençons par le théorème d'arreau qui
permettra à kenneth arrow de gagner le
prix nobel d'économie en 1972 ce
théorème affirme qu'il est impossible de
bien définir les préférences d'un groupe
il s'agit sans doute du moins important
des trois théorème surtout pour la
démocratie
on n'a pas besoin de décrire les
préférences du peuple vis-à-vis de tous
les candidats à la présidentielle a
priori on se moque pas mal de savoir si
le peuple préfère le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste à la lutte ouvrière pour
l'élection présidentielle oui on s'en
fout mais ce n'est pas le cas pour
d'autres votes par exemple pour
l'élection du ballon d'or de la
personnalité préférée des français ou
encore de qui recevra des financements
pour la recherche
dans ce contexte il est important
d'agréger les préférences des électeurs
en une préférence de groupe car pour les
candidats être le 21e préféré par le
groupe peut avoir des conséquences bien
différente par rapport à être le 246e
préférées on pourrait alors exigé que
cette agrégation se fasse de manière
juste
par exemple on aimerait que si tout le
monde préfère griezmann à ribéry alors
le classement de crise man devrait être
meilleur que celui de ribéry
c'est ce que l'on appelle le critère
d'unanimité ou pourra aussi vouloir que
le classement relatif entre kressmann et
ribéry ne dépendent pas de la présence
ou de l'absence de benzema dans la liste
des candidats au ballon d'or c'est ce
que l'on appelle l'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes et on a vu
dans l'épisode président que l'absence
de cette indépendance pouvait causer
l'émergence d'un bipolarisme exacerbé
est bien le terme d'arreau affirme
malheureusement que l'unanimité est
l'indépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes ces deux propriétés pourtant
très désirable sont en fait incompatible
à moins de considérer que les
préférences du groupe seront les
préférences d'un individu du groupe
et pour ceux qui meurent d'envié de
savoir pourquoi c'est le cas bien je
vous en parlais dans l'épisode hardcore
de ce gîte en général donc les
préférences annoncée d'un groupe ne
peuvent pas bien résumé les préférences
des individus du groupe en particulier
ça veut dire que le concept d'intérêt
national ou de ce qui est bien pour un
pays n'a en général aucun sens
à moins que les individus soient tous
identiques un groupe n'a pas de
préférence sont les individus du groupe
qui ont des préférences
il ne s'agit pas là d'une réflexion sur
la nature humaine que sais-je
c'est un théorème mathématique alors il
y aura quand même pas mal de bémols à m
cette interprétation du théorème
d'arreau et on y reviendra dans le
prochain épisode
mais bref avançons
passons aux hommes de guy barde cette
update pour moi cette rame est un vrai
problème pour la démocratie il dit qu'il
faut choisir entre eux ne pas demander
l'avis du peuple ne proposer au peuple
que des référendums est imposé à chaque
électeur un dilemme de vote utile et
pour moi ça fait mal parce que le
dixième du vote utile c'est un sacré
problème on l'a vu dans l'épisode
précédent
il encourage les politiciens s'organiser
sous forme de parti politique et à
placer les électeurs dans des cases
prédéfinies ce qui renforce l'effet de
polarisation idéologique
pire encore si le peuple a voté de façon
utile et non passion c'est vrai
préférence l'élection du président
restera-t-elle légitime comme elle
l'affirmé les candidats élus dell
annonce des résultats
le peuple a parlé s'il l'a voté de façon
utile c'est qu'il n'a pas dit ce qu'il
pensait le peuple a parlé mais il a
menti c'est aussi ainsi que nombre de
débats politiques se pose la question
quel est le moins pire des candidats
trop souvent les électeurs en viennent à
voter contre un candidat plutôt qu'à
exprimer leurs vrais préférence pour
leur candidat préféré
c'est ainsi qu'une grosse partie du
débat politique d'aujourd'hui consiste à
dénigrer les faiblesses des camps
adverses voire à encourager les votes
protestataires plutôt qu'à promouvoir
les idées de son propre camp enfin
laissé la porte ouverte au dilemme du
vote utile c'est limiter l'expression de
l'électorat est dévié une bonne partie
du débat politique vers des stratégies
de vote plutôt que vers les vraies
questions de vision politique
malheureusement le théorème de gebhart
14 wade affirme qu'une démocratie un
site inéluctablement les électeurs à
voter utile autrement dit aucun système
démocratique ne pourra garantir qu'un
président aura été élu conformément aux
vrais préférence du peuple là encore il
ne s'agit pas d'une question d'idéologie
ou de dystopie c'est un théorème
mathématique
à moins que à moins que le système
démocratique en question soit aléatoire
à ce moment là le théorème de guy barde
affirme existence d'un unique scrutin
sans dilemme du vote utile et qui soit
aussi une année
et anonymes unanimes ça veut dire que si
tout le monde veut élire x alors x sera
élu et anonyme ça veut dire que tous les
électeurs ont le même droit de vote vous
savez pas comment dictature le scrutin
de guy barde en question est la
dictature aléatoire aussi connu sous le
nom de l'autocratie
oui cratie pour pouvoir et l'auto pas
comme le loto oui parce que c'est un peu
ça la dictature aléatoire de gebhart
chacun mais un bulletin de vote dans
l'urne avec le nom du candidat qu'ils
préfèrent ensuite on a une urne avec
plein de bulletins de vote
on tire au hasard un butin de vote de
l'urne et le nom du candidat qui est sûr
ce bulletin de vote sera président
créait avec ça il s'agit bien d'une
dictature aléatoire puisque en un
certain sens l'issue du vote est dictée
par les lecteurs dont le bulletin a été
tirée au hasard
cet électeur est donc un dictateur mais
s'il a gagné son pouvoir de dictateur
c'est en vertu d'un tirage au sort d'où
la terminologie l'autocratie le pouvoir
au loto alors ça peut sembler un peu
extrême tout ça s'il est vrai que le
scrutin de guy bardin empêche tout
dilemme du vote utile
on se retrouve quand même avec une
probabilité strictement positive d'élire
un candidat qui sera extrême dans le
sens où il sera détesté par 80% du
peuple ou quelque chose comme ça et
c'est pour ça qu'elle je ne suis pas sûr
que la l'autocratie soit souhaitable
mais je vais quand même me faire
l'avocat du diable les démocratie
athénienne reposer sur une certaine
forme de l'autocratie puisque certains
postes à responsabilités étaient tirés
au sort dans la population
le raisonnement derrière cette logique
reposait sur l'idée selon laquelle le
pouvoir corrompt or choisir la
l'autocratie ses alliés entière toute
ambition de quête de pouvoir ou de
carrière politique
notre explication avancée pour défendre
la l'autocratie est la
responsabilisation des électeurs
certains économistes et philosophes se
plaignent ainsi du fait que les
électeurs ne subissent que rarement les
conséquences de leur vote
il n'y
pas vraiment de coûts directs a mal voté
car la responsabilité du vote et diffuse
cette diffusion de la responsabilité est
d'ailleurs un phénomène bien connu des
psychologues et elle explique pourquoi
vous pouvez agoniser dans une ruelle et
beaucoup de passage sans recevoir aucune
aide
l autocratie a donc quand même pas mal
de bonnes propriétés puisqu'elle permet
de lutter contre les notions de vote
utile de dépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes de quête de pouvoir et de
diffusion de la responsabilité
et pour ce faire il faut bien voir que
la l'autocratie est équivalente à
d'abord tiré au hasard
le dictateur parmi tous les électeurs
puis à suivre les ordres de ce dictateur
aléatoire et ce faisant on peut
court-circuiter l'étape où les autres
électeurs vont voter ce qui lui permet
aux autres secteurs de ne pas avoir à
voter pour rien mais surtout maintenant
le dictateur aléatoire va devoir prendre
des décisions après avoir a été tirée au
hasard
ce qui signifie que tout le monde saura
que la décision vient de lui et on peut
du coup s'attendre à ce que cela
responsabilise aura lieu au dictateur
aléatoire telle est d'ailleurs l'un des
grands principes sous jacents au système
des jurés dans le domaine du droit
ces jurés sont des dictateurs aléatoire
qui sont en charge de la décision quant
à la culpabilité tard un suspect et oui
on utilise encore ou déjà une certaine
forme de l'autocratie pour juger les
criminels de nous soucier des arts c'est
pas tout à fait le cas puisque dans le
cas des jurés il ya en fait plusieurs
dictateurs aléatoire et il va falloir
prendre une décision collective issue
des préférences individuelles de chacun
de ces dictateurs aléatoires donc on a
encore un problème de vote
et d'après les théorèmes de guy bardin
de guy brave satterthwaite il n'y aura
pas moyen de prendre une décision
collective sans s'exposer au dilemme du
vote utile
aller au bout de la logique du scrutin
de guy barde nécessiterait de tirer au
hasard à un unique jurés pour le
jugement de chaque criminel et à faire
de la décision du jury
décision finale quant avec le pa bilité
du suspect ça paraît tout de suite un
peu plus problématique
et vous qu'en pensez vous faut-il
utiliser la dictature aléatoire pour
responsabiliser les électeurs de nos
démocraties et anéantir toute notion de
quête de pouvoir et sera-t-il acceptable
de prendre décision vachement aléatoire
dans nos démocraties
je vous invite à mettre ce que vous
pensez dans les commentaires
la nar fois j'ai essayé de vous
convaincre que les scrutins que l'on
utilise aujourd'hui favorise le
bipartisme et la polarisation des idées
il y en a pas mal parlé vous dans les
commentaires qui ont fait remarquer que
ce n'étaient pas les seules explications
et en effet il n'ya pas que ça comme
explication et on va aborder d'autres
explications notamment dans cette série
sciences un soir je pense notamment la
conjecture économique actuelle mais
aussi des nouvelles façons de
communiquer via notamment internet
favorise la montée des extrêmes aux
aussi never green a pâti nous signale
aussi les effets des médias en effet les
médias ont un rôle très important à
jouer dans la polarisation des idées
surtout aux états unis où les médias
sont très polarisée ceci étant dit oui
je pense qu'on a vraiment souvent
tendance à accuser les médias ou les
politiciens de trop polariser le débat
mais le théoricien des jeux en moi
essayer d'expliquer cela comme étant des
conséquences du système donc c'est pas
tellement la faute des médias c'est
parce qu'on a mis les médias dans une
situation où pour survivre conjecture
économique actuel il leur faut
absolument vendre ce qui s'achète et
ceux qui s'achètent aujourd'hui ce sont
des idées très polarisée et du coup pour
le théoricien des jeux que je suis la
question intéressante c'est pourquoi est
ce que les gens veulent des médias
polarisée vous avez été très nombreux à
se défiler les commentaires ci dessous à
parler du système de vote
am tour puisque deux tours ça a l'air
mieux qu'un tour pourra pas faire trois
tours puis du coux cap tour puisse y ait
un candidat pourquoi ne pas faire un
tour où à chaque tour on éliminerait le
candidat avec le moins de voix est bien
ce système de vote
on peut très bien implémentée et en fait
on n'a pas obligé de voter à chaque fois
on peut juste votée le classement des
candidats coup nous de dire je vote pour
un tel que vous le mettez un classement
à côté du de chaque candidat c'est mon
préféré ensuite le 2 3 etc
et à partir de ces classements il est
tout à fait possible de simuler ce qui
se passerait dans un vote à un tour et
puis juste sortir le résultat ensuite ce
système à voir c'est ce qu'on appelle le
scrutin alternatif où le vote alternatif
et ce scrutin alternatif est utilisé
depuis peu en irlande où je sois si
c'est grâce à la sueur de vidéos de
sites immigrés il ya aussi sûr c'est
nantes qui en a parlé de ce vote
alternatif dans sa vidéo sur les
systèmes de alors ce scrutin alternatif
et il est je pense beaucoup mieux que
les scrute en a un ou deux tours
notamment pour éviter l' indépendance
vous êtes inquiet vision pertinente et
le dilemme du vote utile mais il ne
satisfait pas à ses propriétés c'est à
dire qu'il ya encore des cas si on
réfléchit suffisamment où on a intérêt à
voter utile et où les candidats peuvent
avoir intérêt à ne pas se présenter
parce que sinon ils favorisent un
candidat avec lequel ils ne sont pas
d'accord
bref le scrutin alternatif je trouve que
c'est une bonne solution d'un gêneur
mais c'est pas une solution de
chercheurs de scientifiques est en tout
cas en termes d'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes de dilemme
du vote utile mais aussi en termes de
légitimité de la personne élue je pense
qu'il ya moyen de faire beaucoup
beaucoup mieux et on verra ça dans un
prochain épisode
vous avez été nombreux à signaler un
phénomène qui devrait avantager les
candidats au centre plutôt que ceux sur
les extrêmes savoir le fait que si les
candidats sion sur une ligne
gauche droite alors le candidat qui est
au centre si on l'oppose à quelqu'un qui
est légèrement à sa droite et bien il
aura plus de 50% de la ligne aix orale
alors que s'il est face à un candidat
qui leur main gauche il aura également
plus de 50% de ligne électoral est en
fête et des théorèmes mathématiques
garde tout ça dont on parlera dans cette
sélection 500 vols et du coût a priori
aurait un incitatif pour les hommes
politiques à se rapprocher du centre
et ça c'est clairement quelque chose qui
a pendant très longtemps favorisé les
candidats plus au centre et décourager
les extrêmes et si on considère que les
extrêmes ce sont des alternatives qui
sont détestés par une très grande
majorité du peuple bassa tendance à être
pas si mal de favoriser le centre plutôt
que les extrêmes alors il je pense qu'il
ya une raison pour laquelle cette
explication marche - aujourd'hui qu'elle
n'a pu marcher dans le passé et c'est le
problème de l'abstention
puisqu'aujourd'hui il ne suffit pas
d'être plus à gauche ou plus à droite
que quelqu'un d'autre
il faut aussi fédérer suffisamment les
gens pour qu'ils aillent au vote ou
donnés en tout cas l'impression que
s'ils ne votent pas mais risquent
quelque chose de bien pire que s'il
arrivait à faire élire le candidat qu'il
déteste moi et ça ça a été
particulièrement le cas lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle aux
etats-unis puisque le taux d'abstention
a été de 45% et il semblerait que les
candidats qui sont le moins aller aux
urnes ce conte sont les candidats au
centre ceux qui sont plus indifférent et
du coup pour les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle pour gagner l'élection
présidentielle pour avoir le plus de
votes
il peut être à ce moment là plus
intéressant d'aller chercher les gens
sur les extrêmes elle
et les pousser à aller voter que c'est
de gagner grappiller des gens au centre
qui finalement vont peut voter
plus généralement dans un contexte où
l'abstention est très élevé a priori
pour chaque candidat pour convaincre une
personne d'aller voter pour son candidat
il vaut mieux il me semble de pousser
vers les extrêmes de donner des raisons
assez extrêmes d'exagérer notamment le
cours d'eau le camp opposé pour dire ça
fait très très graves si vous n'avez pas
voté et c'est pour ça qu'il me semble
que les parties aient trop centristes ne
sont en fait pas si alors avantages que
cela parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
amener leurs électeurs à voter et comme
le souligne damien humbert c'est
peut-être parce que clinton et jospin
était pas suffisamment extrêmes qu'ils
ont pas réussi à convaincre les
électeurs d'aller voter et qui sont fait
éliminer notre question récurrente très
intéressante que vous avez laissé dans
mes commentaires c'est le fait que si
ces scrutins pouce aux billes à la
bipolarisation devrait l'avoir déjà
observé parce que ça fait quand même des
siècles que c'est appliquer tout cas aux
états unis
car oui aux états unis ça a clashé déjà
dans le passé c'était la guerre de
sécession dont parle jb cote dans les
commentaires et guerre de sécession qui
peut être vue comme la conséquence de
l'élection au pouvoir d'abraham lincoln
qui était un candidat extrême dans le
sens où il était détesté par une grosse
partie par même la majorité des états
unis alors après au xxème siècle je
pense que les états unis étaient
peut-être moins diviser encore que
pendant les histoires de récession
économique et tout ça on peut là encore
avancé une autre explication le fait que
la guinée les états unis étaient
constamment en guerre pendant l'un thiem
siècle quasiment et que du coup il y
avait toujours un ennemi quelque part
qui pouvaient contre lequel on pouvait
fédérer les américains contre cet ennemi
est d'ailleurs dans l'histoire récente
des etats-unis l'un des moments où les
états unis fait le moins divise
c'est juste après les attentats du 11
septembre
enfin il n'a pas mal parmi vous qui ont
suggéré que je parle de du système de
votation notamment en suisse je vis en
bref ce qu'il faut savoir sur le système
de vote en suisse et que tous les trois
mois
quatre fois par an les suisses peuvent
proposer des nouvelles lois à passer
s'ils arrivent à collecter suffisamment
de signatures à travers une pétition
alors ils peuvent proposer une nouvelle
loi et puis la loi est votée par le
peuple suisse où généralement c'est pas
par toute la suisse ça marche pas mal
par comté et du coup les citoyens ont
beaucoup plus leur mot à dire sur le
travail le vrai travail poétique qui est
pas d'élire des représentants
le vrai travail politique c'est quand
même plutôt d'écrire des lois de
développer des stratégies à l'échelle du
pays
et c'est ce que font beaucoup plus les
suisses que par d autres pays au monde
où sont en délire des politiciens dans
celle au job d'écrire des doigts c'est
ce qu'on appelle la démocratie directe
et ça a le gros avantage de ne pas
polarisé le peuple selon quelques gros
party domino en particulier le peuple ne
votent plus pour un package deal un
espèce de danse ensemble de propositions
le peuple pauvre peut avoir une pensée
beaucoup moins polarisé beaucoup plus
fine avec des opinions distincte sur
diverses questions de société donc ça
très clairement c'est très bien le pis a
l'air de bien marcher en suisse
foucault a noté quelques limites à ce
système d'impôts moins d'un point de vue
prise de décision va s agit de segmenter
les prises de décision de ses devoirs la
politique comme étant des petits
morceaux qui sont suffisamment distincts
à puce pour que chaque question puisse
être traité de façon isolée ça c'est pas
toujours le cas
si on par exemple on veut vu tu voter
les budgets pour différentes choses là
on a une question qui est qui qui mêle
beaucoup d'autres questions et qui est
moins ces câbles dont qui se prête moins
au système de votation était utilisée en
suisse
bref je trouve que le système en suisse
est très très bien et excellent marche
très très bien mais il permet
essentiellement d'adresser des questions
qui sont très ces câbles et où inquiets
de la réponse est speed référendum
oui ou non particulier si on a plusieurs
alternatives pas pour lesquelles choisir
par exemple s'il faut choisir une ou un
pays qui va être la source de telles
matières premières parmi trois pays bas
il faut faire un vote entre trois pays
et là on peut plus faire un référendum
et c'est là qu'il faut des systèmes de
vote plus sophistiqué que le référendum
et c'est là que l'on tombe sur les
problèmes des systèmes de vote et les
théorèmes antidémocratique on l'a vu
aujourd'hui donc il ya pas mal de petits
détails techniques qui ont montré
quelques limitations cap du système
suisse même si encore globalement et les
marches vachement bien en tout cas eu
l'air de marcher h combien un autre truc
qui est assez perturbant lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger en suisse c'est de voir à
quel point les politiciens sont peu
connues sont pas ils n'ont pas
l'impression qu'ils ont tant de pouvoirs
que ça ils ont pas tant de non pas une
mais aura comme laura qu'auraient les
hommes politiques aux etats-unis aux
etats-unis par exemple n'importe quel
nombre de grands politiciens dont l'un
s'est alors voila ca polaris quoi obama
outre un plat toutes citées sont
polarisées en suisse vous dit le nom
d'un des grands politiciens suisses et
puis la part des gens bons ceux qui sont
pas mal engagé les connaissent mais pas
tant que ça et puis ça polaris beaucoup
moins en suisse
il semblerait que être en politique se
soit pas la grande gloire comme sale et
ailleurs et du coup il semble qu'il y a
peut-être moins de quête de pouvoir en
suisse qu'ailleurs aurait plusieurs
explications qu'on peut avancer à cela
déjà les hommes politiques en suisse
seront effectivement moins de pouvoir
qu'ailleurs puisque il ya ces système de
votation direct qui permette au peuple
de changer des lois directement
mais aussi le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
représentant pour cinq ans en suisse
mais c'est un comité de sept politiciens
et qui ça tourne tous les ans ça change
est beaucoup moins deux présidents qui
sert de symbole pour représenter les
suisses ou une partie des suisses
et ça c'est intéressant et j'espère que
j'avais aimé cette vidéo la print fois
on a parlé de scrutin qui vont aussi
c'est à noter nos candidats aux
élections des présidentielles et autres
et en particulier on parlera du jugement
majoritaire qui est je pense celui qui
est le plus prometteur pour les
démocraties dans le futur je dis ça même
si ce n'est pas mon scrutin a préféré et
sont à mon sens pas celui qui utilisent
des ied concluant
comme annoncé dans la vidéo s'il y aura
un épisode de jeudi un épisode hardcore
on verra là l'épreuve des tirs au
tournage
aujourd'hui si vous avez aimé cet
épisode penser à le l'ikea le
commentaire à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci aux tipa report donc et
j'espère que je verrai la prochaine fois
dans la première situation françois élu
messi récupère plus d'électeurs il peut
se retrouver perdant c'est ce qu'on
appelle parfois le paradoxe d'art où que
ce soit dans un scrutin classique à deux
tours ou dans le vote alternatif en
progressant dans l'opinion on peut se
retrouver à descendre dans le classement
c'est quand même absurde outre le fait
que c'est totalement incohérent comme
situation ça ouvre la porte à ce qu'on
appelle du vote